[Music]
my guest this week is an author and
creator of the legendary Dilbert comic
strip Scott Adams
welcome to the Reuben report thanks for
having me I'm very excited to talk to
you but before we get into anything
you've also received the Reuben award
which is for outstanding cartoonists
they spell it the other way though
coincidentally yes although it's not as
prestigious as you might think because
they changed the rules some years ago
that you couldn't win it more than once
ah and there aren't that many
cartoonists in the world so if you stay
alive long enough you got a good shot at
a Reuben award then you're pretty much
gonna win one but you want it [ __ ]
that's over 15 years ago or something
right you want it what's amazing cuz I'm
so young so there you go alright well
I'm very excited to talk to you and
we're gonna we're gonna definitely do
the politic stuff and the Trump stuff
and all that but first for the people
that probably know Dilbert but don't
know much about you personally you have
a sort of interesting backstory of what
kind of led you to becoming a cartoonist
everything you used to be a regular
working man is that fair to say yeah I
was I worked in two big companies now
working in a big bank in the cubicle and
then I went to the phone company and
worked in another cubicle and I actually
like both of my careers ended the same
way I keep forgetting I can say anything
I want on here you could say absolutely
three years there are things that I've
sort of censored that door you know
played down in my backstory about yeah
let's break you out of self-censorship
right now put it right out there yeah my
banking career ended when my boss called
me in her office and told me indirect
language as directly as I'm gonna tell
you that she couldn't promote me any
time in the future because I'm a white
male Wow and she said it wasn't
discrimination per se in the normal
sense it was that the I guess the local
newspaper had discovered that there was
no diversity in senior management and in
order to reverse that since the pipeline
wasn't as good as it should have been
either they pretty much just had to stop
promoting people who look like me Wow so
I said well how long is that gonna last
and she
said something like well it took 200
years to get here so it might take a
while to reverse this yeah I made up
that part but that was implied yeah so I
put my resume together and and I left
went to Pacific Bell started working
there got got on the fast track you know
I was identified as an up-and-comer who
was ready for management and one day my
boss called me into his office and he
said I don't know how to tell you this
but the word has come down I can't
promote white males Wow and it's it was
the same reason it was the newspaper had
discovered that they too had a problem
with diversity as senior management so
that was the point that as I like to say
when you hear the story you say to
yourself wow that must've been a really
bad day for you but turns out that the
moment you realized that your efforts
and your outcomes are not related mm-hmm
it really frees up your schedule for
hobbies I wasn't coming in so early I
wasn't working so late
I started looking for other things to do
yeah the things that I could control my
own faith a little bit so one of the
things I tried to do and it's one of
many things I've tried to do both before
and after Dilbert was to get a comic
strip published I didn't know how to do
that and you know how do you do that way
what's a what's the process for getting
a comic strip started this was
pre-internet right you couldn't find out
anything pre-internet hard to believe
that had a time existed it was the time
but this was a true story it's the this
is sort of the amazing lock part that
everybody has in their story at some
point you know any successful person if
you look at their story it's like I
worked hard I worked harder I worked
hard this really freaking lucky thing
and then something could happen yeah so
in my context were lots of things that
didn't work out for me but I got real
lucky this time and I was came home I
was thinking to myself how do I become a
cartoonist I was flipping through the
channels on TV and it was a TV show on
how to become a cartoonist well but I'd
missed like 28 minutes of the half hour
right and I just figured out well that's
what that must have been about and I
wrote down the name of the host from the
closing credits I wrote in my
regular snail mail letter and I said how
do you become a cartoonist and he
answered two-page letter said by this
book
use these materials and he said whatever
happens don't get discouraged because a
real tough industry and you know you'll
get rejected a lot you but you know
don't give up so I I sat down this was
great I bought the book I got the
materials and put together some comics
that were just single panel comics send
them off to the major magazines they
were rejected mm-hmm you know I just
thought well I tried right it's the best
you can do is try so I put all my
materials in a closet and I forgot about
it
a year goes by then one day I walk out
to the post off or to the mailbox and
there's a letter there from that same
cartoonist who had sent me the original
advice his name is Jack Cassidy mm-hmm
and if he's watching this hi jack
and he he said that he was cleaning his
office and he came across my letter that
was in the bottom of a pile and he said
that he was just writing to make sure
that I hadn't given up Wow and that was
the only reason he wrote and I had given
up and so I thought well maybe he knows
something I don't know maybe you see
something that that even the the
magazines didn't see in my work so I
decided to raise my sights to become to
try to become a syndicated cartoonist
and newspapers all over the world as
opposed to just trying to get out but
you know a comic in the magazine mm-hmm
because I figured if I got rejected at
that it would feel like progress because
I'd begin to reject it at a higher level
you know that would feel good I sent out
my samples and United media one of the
big syndicates called and offered me a
contract yeah I mean that's really just
a great story of not just perseverance
but also that someone else that you
didn't even know really dragged you back
in when you were out and also that your
your work before that you hit that dead
end of you know you're not going any
further here it happened to me because
of your skin it's interesting you the
way you described that you don't sound
like you were you sound like you sort of
understood what they were doing even
though it's know is
he wasn't working for you yeah I have
two minds of that all right there's my
social mind which says yes there was no
diversity in two major companies and
that that's not a long term the
sustainable situation in this kind of a
country mm-hmm so had to be fixed and if
you let it get fixed in its natural
course of events it would take too long
yeah it just would be you know untenable
and it does is also true that wasn't
someone who looks like me a white male
in 1979 gets fired from a job without
doing a bad job or or in this case to
sort of encourage to quit again
I had lots of opportunities so it wasn't
the worst thing in the world for me and
it worked out well obviously yeah so
yeah I have two minds about it I think
it was good for society bad for me at
that moment but it worked out good for
me in the long run yeah what do you
think in 2016 if the same thing happened
to sort of a middle management white guy
and they were told that now do you think
the the reaction from the average person
would be the same do you think the
corporate atmosphere do you think they
would say it in such sort of I think
everything later certain times right so
the tool you need yes you have to adjust
it for the time if it's you know if it's
years ago and you've got slavery you
need a civil war all right you got to go
for the biggest bluntest weapon you can
if it's the you know the seventies and
and you still don't have you know good
representation in in top jobs you need
something less blunt than a civil war
but before more blunt than doing nothing
and just hoping for things to change
yeah so I was in favor of a sort of you
know a punch in the nose sort of a you
know to try to get things kick-started
mm-hmm but now I think things have have
improved
all right nothing's fixed you know we
haven't ended races and we haven't ended
sexism right but there are pockets in
which it really isn't a problem yeah
there are pockets where it's probably a
huge problem but you can choose your
pocket now so if you somewhere where
there's a huge problem we do mostly have
mobility you can quit that job you can
find a place where you do have an
advantage you know I saw a picture today
this running around Twitter The
Huffington Post editorial board
it's on 2% of white women oh yeah I'm
seeing that before so if you're working
for a company you're writer you're a
white woman you got discriminated
against there is some place you can go
right we're probably something like the
opposite is going to happen right so I'm
not saying that's good or bad I'm just
saying that in the world of 2016 you can
leave where you are you have you know
mobility of sorts nobody has perfect
mobility but you can't move right so you
can control your own fate in a way that
you couldn't in 1979 right and it's
funny because if we're talking about the
same Huffington Post picture it's a long
table all of women and the woman who
took the picture is saying look at our
diversity here she means diversity in
that there's a lot of women there's
something to that effect yeah and she's
actually showing you that's just it's
different than just all white men but
it's not really diversity per se there
was amazing bit of blindness that
someone could tweet that publicly and
some proud of it now I think we're all
happy that women that have you know all
the opportunities I literally never met
anybody who thought differently about
that topic so you believe women are
equal before the commenters start going
on and I know it's women or something
well I believe in the equal opportunity
I think every individual is different
but of course you have to have equal you
know access equal opportunity yeah all
right so let's jump forward so now you
you get the cartoon out there and it
starts taking off how much of it was
rattling around all the ideas of Dilbert
which is very much takes place obviously
in the time of your life that you were
working in the corporate atmosphere how
much of those ideas were rattling around
in you while you were doing it I mean
was that just your creative outlet to
not go crazy in a corporate job well it
turns out that Dilbert was sort of the
sum of all my frustrations from my
corporate world and it gave me an outlet
for them I hadn't been thinking in terms
of you know gosh I got to make a comic
about that until I actually started
working on it yeah but it was it was a
handy outlet and by personality I'm
excited by problems I'm excited by chaos
mm-hmm can I swear you can swear away I
told you no rules I wasn't kidding
if things go to [ __ ] yeah suddenly I
feel good yes is it because I there
always opportunity right all right
things are broken at the very least
there's a job for somebody who fixes
broken stuff right so every time
something's broken I think either
there's an opportunity here yeah so I
just love that situation that's probably
a good segue to the Trump stuff but I
want to do some other stuff before
before we quite get there so I was doing
a little research on you you're into
hypnotism
well I ever have noticed you are I'm a
trained certified hypnotist yeah how did
that come to me
well the backstory in that is that my
mother gave birth to my younger sister
while my mother was on hypnosis well
while she was hypnotized my family
doctor was a hypnotist and we hope he
was a medical doctor but I know he was
at least right well you all came out
right yeah we all came out yeah and my
but my mother reports that she felt no
pain did not have any drugs during
childbirth and was awake the whole time
now this is an unusual situation
so even even a well hypnotized person
20% at tops could feel that kind of
extreme phenomena mm-hmm but the other
80% can be deeply influenced and so when
I heard that story I was pretty young
when I heard it I thought what is the
superpower you know and how can I get
that mm-hmm it was part of my process of
trying to accumulate skills that would
layer well on whatever I whatever I was
naturally good at and I thought well
knowing how the human mind works know he
had a influence it no he had a view
hypnotized people it's got to work
everywhere right where would that not be
a good idea right
so do you practice it's um I mean do
people come to you if there's someone
say I have a smoking problem or you know
I eat too much or something you say well
let me hypnotize Ian out of this how do
you use it actually so I've since
broadened what I what I call hypnosis to
include anything in the field of
persuasion influence it could be
advertising you know in the in the
dating realm you know it's it's game
theory or whatever that's called so
there are there are million forms of it
but it's all it's all about how to
influence people in there in the
irrational sense right so you could be
using some of the basics of hypnotist
right now but you're not putting so
people think of hypnotism like I'm
waiting for you to pull out this stop
you know the watch and put me to sleep
but you're saying there's there's sort
of skills and lessons you learn in that
but you can apply that you probably put
into Dilbert and that you certainly are
using on Twitter and things like that so
when I was learning hypnosis of course I
was doing the putting people in
so-called hypnosis trances and doing
things like having them remember their
past lives which by the way is not real
the past live things that are not real
really as I know a couple read people
reading that journey of souls you know
that during exercise don't but it's all
about the past life regression and that
Bowfinger
I can tell you I as practice I would run
a little ad in the local rag to say
coming for $20 I will hypnotize you in
and show you your past lives and person
after person came in and sure enough
under hypnosis they could remember yeah
they're in their past lives but and at
the time I thought I was actually
open-minded about it was like well maybe
I mean how do you rule it out yeah but
I'd have to you do a few you realize
that none of them have lives that you
haven't seen on television like like
nobody said yeah I was uh I was an
Ethiopian you know something that you
wouldn't know how their life was right
everybody was an Egyptian princess or a
Viking right or a cowboy you know I
think that the most exotic one was a
French serf you know I'm thinking ah
nobody is oh and here's the other thing
I had you know person after person come
in and not one of them was Chinese in a
prior life I know dudes math right math
right right man it alone there's a lot
of Chinese a lot of Chinese people yeah
somebody was Chinese in a primary life
if if there were such things as prior
life right so what do you think that
tells you about the human psyche or the
human condition that people you'd put
them under hypnosis which you believe is
a good practice and that ultimately
there so you would say that that's then
their sight subconscious that's just
exercising itself it's just yeah it's
combining with their ego to like just
make up story it's not just their
subconscious it's the fact that the hip
has implanted the suggestion that they
can retrieve their past memory mm-hmm
and so that's enough that they imagine
that they are having actual memories
yeah the main thing you learn to
practice hypnosis to be a hypnotist is
you have to understand that people are
irrational all the time
about everything and if you don't
understand that you can't even do it
mm-hmm because none of it would make
sense for a rational person people
aren't you know if you think people are
affected by data and facts and good
arguments you can't even do him though
the whole thing just falls apart yeah
wait you don't think everyone though is
like that right you you think
100% of the world are rational pretty
much all the time the time and you're
not are trivial so you know if you're
balancing your checkbook or or trying to
decide which object is heavier and how
much you know you need to lift it that's
probably a rational decision but there
are trivial in terms of our lives it's
not going to affect the house you live
you decide to live in the job you take
the person you marry it's not going to
affect you know the way you even the way
you dress most of the time it certainly
won't affect your political choices
right right so you would say those
choices are done in an irrational manner
for most people buying a house I mean
people spend a lot of time yeah I figure
out what house to buy or what career to
go into you think those are done and
through irrational yeah we make our
decisions about people and things in the
first few seconds and then everything
after that is a rationalization I'll
give you a perfect examples from my life
few prior relationships ago we were
looking for a house looked at a bunch of
them we both did like them we drove up
to the the house we ended up buying set
in the car without even going inside the
house yeah looked at each other and
laughed because that was our house cuz
that was it yeah and I don't know why I
mean just had a look at a feel but
without even seeing the inside of the
house without knowing you know what we
would pay or anything like that we had
decided him sure enough we bought that
house yeah like why is it didn't work
out yeah it was great yeah and another
relationship we're looking for a car you
know with my ex-wife
look the car after car we pulled into
one dealer stood there looked at the car
and
laughed didn't know anything about the
card didn't know the specs you know the
mileage didn't know anything I just knew
that was gonna be her car sure enough
yeah so for the people that go to a
gajillion houses and inspect every inch
or that go to 27 car dealerships and all
that that's its sort you would describe
that that's just sort of a different way
of doing things you were sort of going
to find a feeling that's going to appear
right no no I'm saying that everybody's
doing that but I'm aware but you're
aware of the right certainly there are
some some things that would eliminate a
car from your potential if you're
looking for a truck you're not going to
buy a Prius Yeah right so there's a
little bit of common sense in there but
when you get down to those final choices
that's that's all just how it feels
[Music]
you